bonsoir j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour
vous en fait c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour l'économie française
regardez 50 milliards de contrats passés
par airbus et pas fantastique ça surtout
qu'un airbus je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte de la merveille de
technologie que ça représente
je sais pas combien de tonnes de micro
composant électronique qui a la dent
mais ça vous emmène 150 personnes à
l'autre bout de la planète
ainsi dans un fauteuil en sirotant une
coupe de champagne on a beau dire ce
qu'on voudra
c'est quand même une des plus belle
preuve du génie humain alors vous savez
sur internet comment ça se passe on surf
on clique et puis on tombe sur d'autres
informations comme celles ci quinze
mille scientifiques tirent la sonnette
d'alarmé sur la hausse des températures
à cause du réchauffement climatique la
fonte des calottes glaciaires
l'élévation du niveau des océans 6 ou 7
mètres à l'horizon 2100 l'exode de
centaines de millions de migrants
une catastrophe planétaire dont nous
sommes responsables
on dira ce qu'on voudra c'est une des
plus belles preuves de la stupidité
humaine temps et je n'ai pas dit génie
humain juste avant là où ce stupide ite
et surtout si on réfléchi deux secondes
c'est peut-être la magnifique preuve du
génie humain qui en grande partie
responsables de l'énorme bêtise qu'on
est en train de préparer une
contradiction non mais moi ça
m'intéresse en tant que nouveau
biologisme d'il ya peut-être un début de
solution dans notre cerveau alors si on
regardait comment ça fonctionne un
cerveau vous avez toute la partie
extérieure plissée du cerveau qui
s'appelle le cortex le cortex
ça fait de l'intelligence ça fait des
airbus mais juste en dessous tapis au
milieu là le petit animal rouge ce n'est
pas un alien ça s'appelle le striatum
est alors comme c'est au milieu ça c'est
une règle générale dans le cerveau plus
c'est au milieu plus est ancien salaire
ça existait déjà il ya des millions
d'années ce striatum lui fait pas de
l'intelligence non non non
non non il fait de l'émotion brute
il fait surtout du plaisir avec une
molécule dont michel viens de parler la
dopamine
c'est un plaisir chimiques alors il ya
une chose qui est fantastique
aujourd'hui avec les neurosciences c'est
grâce à l'irm et ses grands scanner on
peut savoir maintenant précisément dans
quelles conditions ce striatum nous
donne du plaisir et la première je sais
pas si vous ignoriez penser c'est quand
on arrive à accumuler un maximum
d'informations autour de nous et ça se
comprend
ça se comprend si on se rappelle que ce
striatum existe depuis très très très
longtemps quand on était des hommes
préhistoriques dans la savane parce que
à cette époque-là trouver de
l'information que ce soit une brindille
casser une empreinte de pain d'animal
dans la boue séchée ou une paire d'yeux
derrière un buisson ça pouvait vouloir
dire la survie ou la mort dans le
premier cas un gibier à manger dans le
deuxième cas être un gibier se faire
manger donc à chaque fois que vous
trouviez une petite information dans ce
milieu naturel même infime votre
striatum vous récompenser avec un shoot
de dopamine alors l'information c'est
très bien mais à quoi ça sert eh bien
vous avez compris déjà trouvé à manger
le gibier là une fois qu'on l'a trouvé
vous aviez tout intérêt à cette époque
là à le dévorer entièrement à ne pas en
laisser une seule miette à vous
comporter comme un goinfre à faire une
véritable orgie parce que vous n'étiez
pas sûr de retrouver un autre gibier
semblable avant quelques semaines avant
quelques mois
donc il fallait faire le plein donc à
chaque fois que vous vous comportiez
comme un coin très bien votre striatum
vous récompenser avec un shoot de
dopamine alors manger c'est très bien
pour la survie à court terme mais pour
la survie à long terme
vous savez ce qu'il faut il faut
transmettre ses gènes alors pour
sailhenc il ya quelque chose de très
sympa s'appelle le sexe et alors là
effectivement depuis l'aube des temps
plus vous avez de partenaires sexuels
plus vous transmettez vos gènes donc à
l'époque quand on vivait dans la savane
plus vous avez de relations sexuelles
plus votre striatum vous récompenser
avec de la dopamine
alors ce serait merveilleux s'il n'y
avait pas la compétition pour la
sélection naturelle vous savez comment
ça marche il faut toujours trouver un
moyen de faire un peu mieux que le
voisin est une façon d'y arriver c'est
de minimiser ses dépenses d'énergie
parce que la vie depuis qu'elle existe
dans les océans du précambrien il ya 500
millions d'années a toujours fonctionné
sur ce mode il faut limiter les dépenses
d'énergie dans un milieu hostile
donc à chaque fois que vous pouviez
manger et copuler en faisant le moins
d'effort possible votre assiette homme
vous récompenser avec un shoot de
dopamine et je vous ai gardé le meilleur
pour la fin
c'est que si vous arriviez à faire tout
ça en étant le chef
alors là c'était le gros lot parce que
ça voulait dire plus de nourriture plus
de partenaires sexuels plus de farniente
et donc là votre striatum vous
récompenser mais alors avec un énorme
shoot dopamine donc ça pousse évidemment
à vouloir s'élever toujours un petit peu
au dessus des autres
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a entre les mains
là avec ce striatum on a en fait une
fantastique machine assure vie
totalement rodé très robuste qui existe
depuis l'aube des temps et qui nous a
accompagné jusqu ici ça fonctionne à
merveille c'est presque mieux qu'un
airbus
donc oui le problème mais le problème
c'est que il ne vous aura pas échappé
que nous ne vivons plus dans la savane
autrement dit si je reprends par exemple
le premier élément que je citais la
recherche d'informations alors quand on
vivait dans la savane effectivement le
striatum était devenue très sensible à
la moindre variation dans
l'environnement parce que la savane est
un milieu pauvre en informations
mais aujourd'hui nous ne vivons plus
dans la savane nous vivons dans un monde
saturé d'informations à regarder les
écrans publicitaires regarder quand vous
êtes au travail votre écran d'ordinateur
des bannières publicitaires des pop up
des alertes emails en bas à droite puis
le téléphone qui sonne notification puis
les les fils d'info continue on sait
plus où donner de la tête
et comme notre striatum a été forgée
pour en chercher toujours plus il ne
s'est plus arrêté
et donc on passe son temps vous pouvez
regarder les voisins dans le métro
transporte un escroc laisser le terme ça
veut dire manger de l'information en
bout
ou alors regarder les chaînes
d'information continue et tout ça ça
fait fonctionner l'industrie du
numérique qui en termes d'émissions de
gaz à effet de serre représentent
l'équivalent du transport aérien donc de
nos braves d'airbus et ça on n'y pense
pas toujours
merci petit striatum le deuxième effet
la recherche de nourriture effectivement
vous étiez dans la savane vous tombiez
sur une antilope votre ce qui attend me
disait prends tout de suite tout ce que
tu peux dévorer la maintenant tu ne sais
pas si tu auras demain mais aujourd'hui
ne vivent plus dans la savane nous
vivons dans une société de pléthore
alimentaire il suffit de cliquer pour
avoir à manger
il suffit de descendre dans la rue en
moins de dix minutes pouvait tomber sur
un bon gros hamburger bien gras bien
dégoulinant et le striatum qui n'a pas
été forgées pour s'autolimiter dévore et
nous sommes maintenant 13 % d'obèses la
surface de la planète
l'om est ce nous dit qu'on meurt plus de
suralimentation que de la faim dans le
monde et c'est au prix d'une agriculture
intensive de pesticides de gaz à effet
de serre qui dégage de partout et ça on
n'y pense pas toujours devant son burger
et puis juste après le sexe
alors quand on vivait dans la savane je
sais que c'est une idée fixe un bond
je suis désolé mais quand on voulait
avoir du sexe à l'époque faillite lever
de bonne heure c'est à dire que le
partenaire sexuel fallait aller le
chercher derrière la montagne là
peut-être qu'il fallait se friter avec
le chef de tribu en plus et puis
peut-être avec les rivaux et donc il
fallait vraiment être un mort de faim au
niveau sexe pour survivre et maintenant
vous déplacer ce ce mort de faim
sexuelle aujourd'hui et vous le mettez
façades et des sites de rencontres qui
clique des sites de pornographie
ça donne le chiffre qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui 136 milliards de vidéos
pornographiques visionner à l'année par
l'humanité c'est 35% du trafic internet
et c'est de nouveau des serveurs qui
tournait de l'énergie qui se dissipe
dans l'atmosphère simplement pour un
petit instinct débridée alors notre
désir de moindre effort dont je parlais
tout à l'heure alors si vous vouliez du
confort à l'époque préhistorique
tout ce que vous pouviez avoir de mieux
c'est peut-être une fourrure alors il
fallait quand même aller se faire un
ours au pieu quoi donc
et cette année la fourrure puis là vous
aviez un peu de confort mais plus
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui tout est fait pour ça et on
sait pas s'arrêter je sais c'est
évidemment le numérique
à l'aller les plats qu'on peut commander
à distance et les assistants vocaux on
n'a même plus besoin de se lever de son
canapé pour commander des sushis basse
et les berline confortable l'ameublement
et l'électroménager tout ça ça ça fait
sortir des ressources naturelles de la
terre qui aujourd'hui est au bord de
l'épuisement
et puis notre désir de statut social
s'élever au dessus des autres facebook
instagram 3 milliard d'utilisateurs
qu'est ce qu'ils font à longueur de
journée clic clic clic pour amasser un
peu plus de like que le voisin un peu
plus de statut social puis en mai sa
plus belle photo
et puis les arguments pour vendre des
automobiles aujourd'hui dans les
publicités vous verrez le grand argument
ses larmes fatale c'est l'auto
suréquipés parce que suréquipés ça veut
dire qu'on peut peut-être aller
grappiller une petite option en plus que
le voisin ou alors le suv qui permettent
d'être un peu plus haut que le voisin
donc merci à notre striatum de nous
emmener droit dans le mur
bon maintenant qu'on sait ça on peut
dire bah on va satisfaire ses besoins
ancestraux avec modération
ça marche pas comme ça non non ne savons
pas si vaincu cette petite bestiole
on a découvert il ya quelques années que
les cellules nerveuses qui libère la
dopamine qui nous donne du plaisir
si vous leur donnez tous les jours la
même quantité de stimulation et ben ils
finissent par fermer le robinet à
dopamine fini frustration ennuis
lassitude est le seul moyen de relancer
la production de dopamine
c'est d'augmenter les doses autrement
dit nous sommes habités par un principe
de croissance neuronale biochimiques qui
nous habite depuis très longtemps qui se
répercute dans le dogme de la croissance
économique
ce qui donne une indication de la
difficulté que nous aurons à en sortir
alors on peut se dire maintenant on voit
l'horizon qui s'avance dans trente ans
la catastrophe les marches pour le
climat nous le dise donc on va réagir ça
marcherait oui si notre striatum était
sensible à la profondeur du temps le
problème c'est que les neurones à
dopamine
ne s'allume que quand on leur donne un
plaisir tout de suite maintenant
d'où l'instantanéité de nos modes de
consommation
si vous promettez une récompense dans un
an 10 ans 20 ans aucune décharge
neuronale en termes de dopamine notre
striatum est aveugle autant et c'est ce
qui fait qu'on est absolument incapable
de sentir l'urgence est contraint
continue business à juju recommande donc
à ce stade nous sommes avec un cerveau
qui a été pendant des millions d'années
notre meilleure alliée et qui
aujourd'hui est devenu notre pire ennemi
il est en train de creuser notre tombe
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire face à
ça moi je vous le dis tout de suite il
ya des gens qui disent bayac a enlevé le
striatum non parce que l'on peut pas
vivre sans dopamine et sans plaisir à
essayer vous verrez c'est encore pire
après ya des effets rebonds après on se
lâche c'est carrément la débauche
non il faut obtenir de la dopamine par
d'autres moyens
il ya trois pistes la première c'est
obtenir de la dopamine avec moins de
stimulation vous allez me dire c'est
contradictoire avec ce que je viens dire
pas forcément si on remet le cortex dans
la boucle moi je me souviens d'une
histoire que m'a raconté christophe
andré psychiatre à l'hôpital sainte-anne
à qui on collabore au journal et qui me
racontait comment il prenait en charge
parfois des groupes de personnes qui
sont dans des situations d'alimentation
compulsive problèmes de poids justement
et il me parlait d'une expérience
s'appelle l'expérience du grain de
raisin
c'est à dire que vous allez acheter un
dégré insectes comme au supermarché dans
un sachet puis vous dites aux patients
maintenant prenez un grain de raisin et
au lieu de le manger de l'enfourner
comme vous faites d'habitude devant
votre télé regardez-le quelques instants
observé lus à la lumière du couchant
regardez c'est joli et délicat repli
puis hume et son parfum petit peu
acidulées prenez le temps une minute
deux minutes puis butelle dans la bouche
fait le passé autour de votre langue et
pendant tout ce temps ce sont des
stimulations qui sont recueillies par
notre cortex par notre striatum qui
libère de la dopamine et qui a du
plaisir et ça peut durer comme ça
pendant un quart d'heure avec un grain
de raisin je ne blague pas essayer et
bien souvent les gens vous disent j'ai
l'impression d'avoir fait presque un
petit repas l'avantagé c'est que en un
quart d'heure il ya déjà des mécanismes
de satiété qui peuvent s'installer
et puis on a vraiment
on fait beaucoup de sensations avec peu
de choses donc c'est une voix a
développé par la discipline il faut y
penser c'est le petit geste qu'on peut
faire pour notre environnement tous les
jours mais qui cumulés sur des milliards
d'individus pourraient faire énormément
la deuxième piste c'est de se dire qu'on
va obtenir de la dopamine non pas en
accumulant pour soit toujours plus de
stimulation mais peut-être en partageant
par l'altruisme
vous allez me dire c'est des idées en
l'air mais il ya une expérience qui ait
lieu il ya deux ans à l'université de
zurich qui a montré que ça pouvait être
le cas on donnait à des des participants
une somme d'argent leur disant vous
pouvez garder l'argent pour vous si vous
voulez ou le partager avec un inconnu
que vous ne verrez jamais alors on a
constaté une différence entre les hommes
et les femmes c'est là que les hommes
garder l'argent et dans le lit à même
leur striatum s'activaient mais alors
bien fort et mais par contre chez les
femmes y en avait une grande partie qui
partageait pas spontanément et la grande
découverte c'était de voir que leur
striatum s'activaient il y avait une
libération de dopamine chimiques plaisir
chimiques de données donc c'est pas
juste du sacrifice idéologique s'il ya
un vrai plaisir qui peut apparaître chez
beaucoup de personnes surtout des femmes
et on s'est rendu compte que c'est parce
que souvent les petites filles en fait
on les félicite quand elle se comporte
de façon altruiste et en les félicitant
en fait on leur confère un statut social
et ça c'est un des grands stimulateur
ancestrale du striatum ça veut dire
qu'on peut associer un plaisir lié au
statut social avec des comportements
altruistes simplement il faut décider de
le faire avec tout le monde pas
seulement que les petites filles
et puis de le faire sérieusement et
peut-être qu'on aurait des générations
d'altruiste qui prendrait plaisir à ça
et puis enfin je voudrais vous parler
pour terminer de la vraie nourriture du
cerveau qui n'est peut-être nil la
vigilance ni le sexe ni lé confort tout
ça mais le savoir et là encore je parle
en connaissance de cause il ya quatre
ans maintenant à l'université de
californie des travaux ont révélé que le
simple fait de poser des questions sur
des énigmes
essayez de d'apprendre des choses de se
cultiver provoquer une libération de
dopamine dans le striatum quand on
prenait le temps de développer cette
curiosité et que ça avait même un impact
favorable sur la mémoire
donc si nous nous y prenions bien nous
pourrions créer des générations
d'addicts aux savoirs avec un appareil
de carbone zéro et beaucoup de bien-être
je crois que ce serait la table finale
pour se réconcilier avec notre cerveau
ce cerveau qui a été notre meilleur
allié comme gèlèdé pendant très
longtemps qui aujourd'hui est devenu
notre pire ennemi mais dans lequel on
pourrait de nouveau harmoniser l'immense
pouvoir que nous confère notre cortex et
l'immense réservoir de désir de notre
striatum je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]